a big week for the eurozone as the
debate about the future of economic and
monetary union with the euro at its
heart gathers momentum what's good
what's bad what needs changing in euro
zone's governance regime 20 enough says
performs Perez author of a report on the
question mucho mas que todo por todo lo
siento novo la flesche I do basic info
Sergio certain Haigler for moody Eledone
pour permettre de bajo new economy
community he's way more selfies the
knuckle spray her report backs the three
pillar approach investment minimizing
deficits and structural reform but
applied more precisely to different
conditions in different countries is how
the vote went credible economic
governance is first and foremost also
implementing what you have agreed to do
to deepen our monetary union we first
need need to make sure that the current
system actually works el marco africa
sado porque con las normas que nos vemos
aplicado y tenemos mess deficit mess n
da da miento mro the debate is far from
over EU heads meet on thursday and
friday for talks on deepening economic
and monetary union following proposals
put by the five presidents of the e
u--'s main political and financial
institutions